We use scientific notation to write extremely large numbers or small numbers,
let's review that real quick. At the beach, we could think about measuring a
tiny grain of sand, that grain would measure this many meters. We can rewrite
this number in scientific notation, using what we learned from Unit 1. For
scientific notation, the absolute value of our first number, a, must be greater
than or equal to 1, and less than 10. So we know we need to move the decimal to
the 6. We'll have 6 and 25 hundredths. Next, we need a power of 10 so we can
move this decimal back to its original position. I know this decimal should move
five places to the left in order to get this number. So my exponent is negative
5. We learned about negative exponents at the beginning of this unit and this
should make a ton of sense now. Multiplying by a negative power of ten makes a
number smaller because we're really dividing the number by a power of 10. And,
if we carried out the math and moved the 10 to the denominator and then divided
by 100,000 we would get this decimal. And, remember a positive exponent would
make sense here. Positive powers of ten make numbers larger but this one's
smaller.